皆さん　こんにちはあああああああああああ
はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんは最近運動をしていますでしょうか
まぁだんだん暑くなってきて皆さんも運動をしたい季節になったと思うんですけども
そんな運動をしたい季節皆さんどういう運動をされますでしょうか
やっぱり運動をするなら楽しい運動がいいと思うんですよ
そこで誰でも簡単にできるスポーツ
その中でも1番手っ取り早いと思ったものが
スポーツテストで皆さんもやったことがあると思うんですよ
反復横跳びのやり方の説明をします
反復横跳びとは
まず100㎝の間隔で平行に引かれた3本の線の中央の線をまたいで立ちます
合図と同時に自分の右側に最初ステップし、て
右側のラインを右足を超えるかラインに触れたら
次は左にサイドステップをして中央ラインに戻ります
で、また左、右、左、右って
線が3本あってその線をこうやってまたぐだけっすこうやって
これが100センチ間隔
通常のルールだと20秒間で何回それができるかっていうのを数えるわけなんですけども
運動不足なんで今わたくしは運動がしたい
は〜んぷくこよとびっ
まぁ通常はその20秒間やってなんか何回できればいいみたいな感じなんですけども
もう違うジャンルにしてしまいます
20秒間とかそういうのじゃなくて
体力的な面も考えて読めない部分がたくさんあるんですけど
なんか反復横跳びって僕ちょっとナメてるんすよ
クソ簡単じゃないっすか
だってこうやってさ　こうやって
こうしたいがだけ　こうしてればいいだけの話なんで
これを20秒間やってもそんな疲れないんで
これを10000回やればどれぐらいつかえ、疲れるの
ﾌｳｳｳｳｳ
これを10000回やるとどれぐらい疲れるのか
そしてその10000回やると何秒くらいかかるのかっていう
タイムをちょっと測ってみたいと思います
これが多分全国の男子諸君の平均タイムになるので
皆さん参考にやってみてください
じゃあ準備します
えー結構やなー　こんなあったっけ
ここが0ってことでしょ
えー待って10000回ちょっと嫌な予感がしてきたなどうしよう
待って本当に10000回か1000回でよかった気もするが
やふへゐ）行きます　反復横跳び10000回
よーいスタート
犬）1.2.3.4.5.6.7.8.9. ...
あ、いけるぞこれ
待ってやばい　やばい
いや待ってまじやばいこれ
‪待ってほんとに笑えないこれやばい
あーまじ間違えたこれ10000回無理だ
今何回？
待ってほんとに　想像の　800倍きついっすよこれ
ヤバイミスった動画ミスや
足が…
500行きました
結構　500で
人間の限界を超えた気がしますね
ハッハッハッハッハッハッハ
[ガタッ]ぃやああああああああああ
ｗｗちょっとｗ俺げん、これ限界っすわこれ
やふへゐ）はははｗｗｗ
僕の全力疾走っすわ
あ、見えた見えた見つけた
これいい
体を方向を動かすことによる体力消費が激しんで
体をone wayに固定して動くことによって
きついっすわ
犬）98.99.1000
タイムは
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
無理だ　もう本当に無理っす
あのというわけでえー12分何秒でしたっけ？
〉12分30秒
えっとはじめしゃちょーの
反復よとっこ… 1000回記録は
えー
12分でし、12分30秒
はっはっはっは
あのほんとに多分これ10000回やると
運動をしてない人は確実に死ぬんですけど
多分運動をしてる人もそこそこ動けなくなっちゃうと思うんで
1000回にしておきましょう
10000回は体力と時間に余裕があるときにやろうと思います